pour toi mon colis recommencera
salut tout le monde je suis pour brut oz
events est un marathon caritatif en live
sur la plateforme de streaming twitch
chaque année des dizaines de streamer
venus de toute la france essayer de
récolter des fonds pendant un week-end
pour une association l'année dernière il
avait réussi à lever la somme record de
10 millions d'euros pour action contre
la faim et cette année ça sera pour des
associations environnementales les
streamers ont tout juste en train
d'arriver ils sont à la gare donc on va
aller les rejoint
tout d'abord bus magique
on va prendre du lsd ça ira pas la vidéo
ça
[Musique]
j'avais un peu d'appréhension parce
qu'évidemment on a fait énormément
l'année dernière beaucoup de dons et
cetera donc du coup les gens s'en va
jouer est ce que ça va te rejoindre
dernière nous on sait pas on est un peu
dans l'expectative mais en tout cas il
ya des nouveaux qui sont à cette année
dont se plaignent à tour ton qui est là
qui n'était pas la dernière il ya plein
de nouveaux donc c'est cool il ya les
nouveaux gens à qui donc se déplacer
et c'est vraiment stressé et non je suis
pas un gars très fier d'eux
naturellement mais par contre certains
devraient avoir peur déjà je pense
ce qu'ils ont pas prêt je pense bien
falloir me contenir j'apprécie d'être là
et j'espère que blanc tout donné 2000 %
on espère que les gens seront contents
quoi je pense que ça va être très cruel
moi j'ai vraiment très hâte de retrouver
les copains je sais que va y avoir
énormément de choses qui sont créés
moi je me suis même demandé mais qu'est
ce que je fais seulement streamés sur ma
chaîne qu'elle manque il ya des trucs
par ci par là par les copains ça va être
vraiment très très chouette je pense
qu'on va être tous soudés et
un max de dieu
les associations présentes
fait chaud
j'ai même pas posée
dommage que les vannes sur un vide
dommage dommage
et en vrai on aurait mis l'euro millions
fait 1000 g moi ce que j'ai dit dans le
train c'est si on arrive à passer la
barre des 2000 c'est symbolique tam ex
2007 jeunes mix avec des jeux très juste
mais c'est un voyage à un mois de loyer
à paris qui se strie
l'avant oliva qu'il est bon car chabal
ça va pas cha cha va très bien très bien
même
oiseaux n'ont réussi à y aura bien un
truc pas mal parce que bon je
l'annonçais mais ya pas mal de choses
qu'on allait parler des choses qui
entoure la question pour l'influent
maire a prévu un regard positif avec
alain chabat en tout cas sur le papier
l'émission va très bien marché et ça
dépendra comment la saison mais moi j'y
crois tous les parisiens et quelques
autres sont arrivés on va à la salle
s'installer on est jeudi après-midi
s'installe un petit peu après on va au
zénith saisi event a déjà commencé
depuis en fait lundi mardi ou tout latex
s'installe au zénith dans la salle et
pour les streamer ça commence à peu près
jeudi le dialogue passe il faut se lever
tôt pour prendre le train pour les
parisiens moi ça va je joue à domicile
là ça fait une semaine que travail il ya
le montage du concert le montage de la
salle parce qu'il faut amener les tables
des cas le réseau l'élec et
voilà c'est là bas
et voilà et c'est beaucoup de
préparation mais on est prêts on n'a
jamais été aussi prêt à les ramener vous
justement où ce qui est vrai je suis
fort
et voilà on est arrivé devant moi moi ce
n'est pas une découverte en quelques
heures mais voilà la salle de cette
année elle est belle
m pas trop dans le jura non franchement
il ya eu pire
c'était pas évident parce que comme on a
été obligé de prendre la rentrée pour
les dates de l'événement l'été les gens
sont pas là donc du coup personne
réponse mais mais honnêtement on avait
une grosse équipe c'était une prépa bien
bien fait à la devance donc franchement
plutôt cool enfin là on est tous plutôt
en avance comparé à d'habitude je trouve
tous tout le monde est plutôt serein
donc faut voir le concert ce soir je
sais pas ça je m'en suis pas occupée
pour le tout mais j'ai plutôt confiance
est plutôt ça
cet après midi l'escrimeur vont
installer leur set up pour qu'ils soient
prêts pour demain et ensuite en fin de
journée il y aura un gros concert au
zénith de montpellier avec du public il
y aura notamment les artistes berry wam
frenchies soprano big flo et oli et y
aura aussi la stream aux little big wave
qui va chanter avec le youtuber pv nova
je suis prêt
[Musique]
quand on est un grand écran mobile trend
micro j'ai l'habitude de bricoler c'est
ma fille là c'est plus du bricolage
intiale dire c'est ça marche ou ça
marche ça marche ça ton respectueux le
bricole où il est vrai mais il est vrai
qu'on le fait de retrouver cette
atmosphère on a des gens qu'on aime bien
et tout ça fait du bien je pense que ça
geste en vrai ça se présente plutôt bien
on a du réseau on à l'électricité donc
des façades pour un peu plus de temps
mais là tout et tout écart est
maintenant comme la plupart on prend pas
nos ordinateurs du qu'on doit tout
réinstaller ici nous apprend un peu de
temps ça prend un peu de temps mais on
est jeudi mais je ne commence que demain
à 18 heures donc en bref on est pareil
c'était un grand
maître audience était encore plus grand
c'était bon c'était vraiment petit
le bourg et lors de laquelle il m'a dit
on de la championne n'avait pas la clé
mahé dernière il y avait une odeur en
tout cas les dernières photos tandis
qu'areva buzz et tu as entendu parler
nous on l'a senti j'ai dû coucher puis
j'ai mis deux fois plus de des eaux pour
être sûr de partir de la mer n'était pas
de progrès un coût
fiscal yarka les rebelles
sont déjà occupés ont commencé à être
sept c'est très grand en fait j
bizarre de la voir en vrai c'est de bien
peu un classique on en parle moins
surprenant génération c'est
agacé le divin
il faut que j'essaie j'ai pas ouvert mon
truc depuis un an et demi après quitté
tpr et là j'ai un peu ce soir on est en
deçà
c'est ok
mais là c'est elle on va se régaler
encore une fois on ne pouvait pas
tranquillement on va du cosplay la de la
rigolade on n'a pas beaucoup dormi donc
on va aller à l'hôtel heureusement qui
est à côté on allait on va se reposer je
pense ce soir le concert concert ça va
être fou ça ça fait deux ans qu'ils font
ça va c'est le zénith sais pas s'ils
allaient prochaine c'est stade de france
bonsoir à tous je rappelle que le bus
part du crowne plaza dans trois minutes
merci à tous de vous déplacer vers
l'hôtel pour promouvoir le concert on
laisse son pc en plomb a raté jeter à
l'eau
[Applaudissements]
je vais accueillir les deux premiers
artistes un triomphe s'il vous plaît
pour pv nova et little big wave
c'est fou
ats
m
[Musique]
sur le
on ça a commencé c'est super armure
[Applaudissements]
une fois l orchestre
tu veux
[Applaudissements]
on
était j'étais vraiment vraiment ému à la
fin du retour des gens de la générosité
est trop mou est trop fier d'eux
trivia c'est juste mon troisième concert
de sa vie je lui mets un arc s dans les
pattes des 6000 personnes devant elle
les jours j'ai cru que j'allais pleurer
au milieu de la scène tellement janvier
sous le monde gt gt supprimant j'avais
la voiture n'était pas ce que j'avais
envie de pleurer moi j'étais là sans nom
les chansons j'étais comme ça c'est une
belle ouverture de cet event ça va être
génial ce soir on a des super artiste et
maintenant je suis très contente d'être
passée la première parce que maintenant
je vais pouvoir des comptes décompresser
et danser le shimmy chira vie
[Musique]
didier
c'est certain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est que les deux
fait carrière
ouais c'est de la bombe des
bonnes stats là j'ai vu cent mille
juste un truc qu'on entre sur scène est
ce que vous préférez nous accueillons
discuterons vous entrez sur un morceau
jusqu'à 21h ok 20 18 masculins
ouais bien sûr nation mesdames et
messieurs je vous le disais tout à
l'heure ils ont rempli des stades qui
sont de moins en moins habitués au petit
public il va falloir leur montrer qu'ils
vous êtes ici à montpellier mesdames et
messieurs big three
[Applaudissements]
et ça fait 1 2
[Musique]
hier travaux
les amis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
merci des séries
petit petit souci là on voulait rentrer
sur scène
hélas la régie me dit vous mettez pas
trop près de la semaine ce qui a des
flammes enfin les flammes prévu un bien
sûr qu'on fasse gaffe un peu ça va aller
montpellier
trop bon de sortie
[Applaudissements]
tout le temps
qui tous
tout le monde
[Musique]
pro b
c'est beaucoup
l'ambiance et son son public il est
chaud au centre montpellier ils étaient
venus pour tout casser pour mettre le
feu
mais
l'allumette était là j'ai fait des
efforts au niveau sport 20 ou à papa et
j'ai fait des pompes m tu as fait
d'époque mais c'est pas que des pompes
on est dépendant ni thought to tape des
mains libres tombe dessus et parce qu'on
est venu à son stade à lyon un niveau
physique ce n'est pas ça
les champs quand il sort il s'agit de ce
genre de sujet les gens les jeunes
surtout sont très très très réceptifs
parce qu'ils pensent à leur avenir
contrairement à ce qu'on peut croire tu
vois les jeunes
françoise une sauce c'est pour ça qu'ils
déchirent et la regarde ton talent bien
ce concert et les finissants encore
chaud j'imagine ceux qui sont devant
leur stream et demain ça va tout péter
on va tous aller ferry de 28 cela est
courte mais intense et de là on se
retrouve à 18h pour le g20 merci à tous
et esi est votre concept
[Applaudissements]